(playful music)
- [Narrator] This is Musetta.
She's a common squirrel monkey,
but there's nothing common about her.
Squirrel monkeys are from the rainforests
of the Amazon Basin.
Their fur can range from olive
green to yellow in color.
They have long tails,
which help them balance
on canopy branches, and they subsist
on a diet of fruit and insects.
They communicate by using up
to 30 different vocal calls
and can be quite loud
when they get alarmed.
Although they are labeled least concern
on the Endangered Species List,
they are made vulnerable by
the increasing deforestation
of their natural habitat.
This is the squirrel monkey.
(bright tones)